hey there in this lecture you're going
to learn how to create your very first
flexbox layout using the example you can
see in the page here I've already added
a little bit of styling in the basic CSS
file though this has nothing to do with
the Flex box itself here in the
index.html
you can see the markup for the example
it contains a name element with the
class of container and inside of that
container we have three divs which are
in the Flex items as you might guess
we're going to create a navbar here as
this displays whole search and logout
now the first thing you need to
understand is the concept of a container
and its items that's always how you
build up your flexbox layout they don't
have to be divs or navs could have been
UL element and this could be a list
element or whatever you want as long as
they are directed children of the
flexbox container they turn into flex
items so let's turn this example here
into a flexbox layout i'm gonna head
over to the index dot CSS and i've
already given the container a border
which you can see around the example
here but as we haven't done anything
else with this layout these divs will
now just stack themselves on top of each
other so to turn this into a flexbox
layout simply give the container a
missplay um flex as you can see but
automatically lines up the elements
horizontally as opposed to vertically as
it was before so by default flex box
will distribute the items going from
left to right and as you also can see
the flexbox container is by default a
block element as it takes up all
available space in the width except for
the little margin i've added to the left
and right hand side okay so that was a
very quick introduction to flex box in
the next lecture i'm going to teach you
about the concept of access as that is
core in order to understand flex box
properly so I'll see you there
heyyyyyy in this lecture I'm going to
teach you about access as that is a core
concept you need to understand in order
to work properly with the flexbox
because a flexbox container always has a
direction by default this direction is
horizontal because that's how it lays
out its items starting here on the left
hand side and going towards the right
hand side what we then say is that our
main axis goes from left to right along
the row and we also have a cross axis
which goes from top to bottom now the
reason you need to understand this is
that we're using different CSS
properties in order to position our
content along the main axis which goes
horizontally in this case and the cross
axis which goes vertically in this case
however that's not always the case as we
can also flip the direction of the
flexbox container let's do that we'll
head over to the container and give it a
reflects direction by default this one
is set to row so if we write row nothing
will happen however if we change this to
column now as you can see not results in
stacking the items from top to bottom
going downwards instead of going from
left to right and now the main axis
actually goes from top to bottom and the
cross axis goes from left to right now
we're going to flip this back to row as
I found that I've used the default
direction much more often than the
column direction when building websites
so I won't focus on that in this course
as I wanted to be as practical as
possible but I want you to be aware that
the main axis is horizontal because the
Flex Direction is set to roam however it
can be vertical as well okay in the next
lecture I'm going to teach you how to
position items along the main axis so
stay tuned and I'll see you there
hey there in this lecture I'm going to
teach you how to position the items
along the main axis which goes as you
hopefully remember from left to right
and that's because we probably don't
want all of our items to be squeezed
together over here at the left hand side
because we might for example want a
little bit of spacing in between them or
maybe move the log out item over to the
right hand side so let's jump into the
code and see how we can achieve this
we're going to use the property called
justify confident as that's the one
which controls the content along the
main axis justify content can take a
range of different values and actually
want to paste in a few of them here for
you to experiment with towards the end
of this lecture by default justify
content is set to flex start meaning
that the content is squeezed together at
the start of the main axis which is the
left hand side if we change it to flex
end and as you can see the content will
move over to the end of the main axis on
the right hand side we can also use
Center and that will of course send
correct now it also has a few other nice
properties which start with space let's
try this space round this value will
give each item an equal amount of space
on its left hand side and right hand
side because as you can see when two
items are besides each other the space
is twice as wide as if as if it's only
an item and then the start of the
container or the end of the container
because this space here is twice as wide
as this space here and this space here
so what I want you to do now is try out
these last two values for yourself space
between and space evenly so pause the
screencast and change this value here to
these two and observe how the items are
laid out in the main direction and try
to understand how these three space
between space evenly and space around
differ from each other once you've done
that just resume back to the screencast
and then we'll continue with the course
okay so hopefully you have been doing a
little bit of experimentations
you have any questions feel free to ask
them in the Q&A section and in the next
lecture you're going to learn even more
about how to position items along the
main axis so I'll see you there
hey in this lecture I'm going to explain
how you can adjust the position of
single items along the main axis using
the good old technique of margin Auto
because these various justify content
values are nice and handy but they don't
always do what you want them to do for
example I might not want to have the
items spread around the container like
this
perhaps I want the home and search over
on the left-hand side and the logout
over on the right-hand side and that's
not something you can do with any of the
justify content values alone
so let's actually remove justify content
so that they're all squeezed together on
the left hand side as that's the default
layout now I don't do is move the logout
item over to the right-hand side and as
that forces us to target that item
itself I've given all three items class
names home search and logout so to
change the logout item will simply
target it and give it a margin on the
left hand side and set that through Auto
run as you can see that pushes the
logout item all the way over to the
right-hand side and this space here now
is the margin left of the logout item so
this is normally how I assume single
items along the main axis if we wanted
to have both the logout and the search
item over on the right hand side we
could simply target the search item
instead so if I remove it from logout it
will be placed in the default layout and
then I'll simply give the search margin
on the left side instead and as the
search is before the logout in the
mark-up it'll push the log out as well
to the right-hand side when it adds a
margin to its own left-hand side now I
want to give you a little task first I'm
going to remove this one here and I'm
going to set me let's defy confidence to
me flex and it pushing all the items
over to the right-hand side what I want
you to do now is to make the home item
rather appear here on the left-hand side
I want you to do it by adding a margin
to the Oh Michael
go ahead and do that then just resume
and come back to the screencast when
you've managed to do it and then I will
show you the solution as well okay so
hopefully you pause the screencast and
write that out what you need to do is to
give this home item margin on its
right-hand side so we'll do margin right
in set that to auto and boom rad
purchase the home item from this space
here to this space here and this is now
the margin okay now is it for this
lecture in the next one you're going to
learn a really cool property called flex
which allows you to have responsive with
on the items themselves so I'll see you
there
Hey in this lecture you're going to
learn about the Flex property which
allows you to set the width of the items
according to the width of the entire
container meaning that they will become
responsive that's unlike our current
items which stay the same regardless of
the width of the container so if we want
all of these items to stretch across the
entire container and grow and shrink
with it we'll simply convict the items
with that container select all the
direct children would also our dims and
then give them a flex property of one as
you can see they now take up an equal
amount of space 1/3 each and they grow
and shrink with the size of the
container now there's a little bit of
magic here as flix
is actually a shorthand for three other
properties rayar flex grow flex shrink
reflects races however I don't dwell
about this now because I think there are
other parts of flexbox that are more
important to learn before you jump into
understanding these three so we'll start
by using flex the easy way and then in a
later screencast I'll explain these
three in depth but for now I'll just
keep them here to remind you that this
is a short app now setting flex to one
is much better than the old way of doing
it where it'll probably set me with to a
percent finish like this Apple it works
cover now you have to change this number
whenever you wanted to add a new item in
the container
whereas with Flex you can simply add as
many items as you want and flexbox will
take care of doing the maths for you and
making all of them responsive so let's
actually try that out
Oh turn on the Flex again and let's
simply add a fourth item here we'll call
it profile let's run the code as you see
Lex automatically allocates space for
all of the items according to how we've
specified it here now each of them take
a
25% of the width and they grow and
shrink with the container we can also
target specific items let's say that for
example we want the search item here to
be twice as wide as the rest of the
items then we'll simply do container
search and set Flex to queue that's you
can see it's now twice as wide as the
three other items
the reason I'm specifying container and
then the child that container which are
the class of syrups is because doing
just dot search wouldn't work as this
selector here is more specific than this
one and that's how CSS worked works if
this one is more specific given that has
both a class name and tag name its
styling will reprioritized above the
less specific styling added hair that's
only using just a class name so let's
use both dot container and the child of
the container that's the class of search
so that was just a little digression
about CSS selectors so while this
example here is nice for learning I
can't say that I very often use this way
of creating layouts where all of the
items are well and then some of them are
2 or 3 or whatever what I found to be a
more realistic use case is to have one
of the items doing all the flexing while
the others stay at a fixed width and we
can achieve that by simply removing the
Flex one on all the items except the
search now as you can see the home
logout and profile have a fixed width
while the search item growing and
shrinking with a width of the container
and now we can also remove the
specification here and just use dot
search ok now I want to give you a
little task and before that I'm going to
remove this profile item so that we only
have three now as you can see the search
in the middle that's all the flexing
while the home and logout are fixed with
what I want you to do now is to make
this layout do the exact opposite
meaning that the search item will have a
fixed width while the home and the
logout will grow as you widen the
contain
so pause the screencast and do that and
when you come back I'm going to show you
how I would do it okay so hopefully you
pause the screencast and did the task
now I'm gonna show you how I would do it
so I'll start by making the search item
fixed with again to do that we can just
remove this young here now it's fixed
will and rather give this value to the
home icon
now that is doing all the flexing and
what I also won't do now is to change
this to one because when this is the
only item doing the flexing it doesn't
matter if this is one or two or hundred
or a thousand or whatever you want and
therefore I think it is to just have
less fun now we also have to give the
same behavior to the logout pick'em so
I'll simply log out and just the stack
we have earthly home and the logout item
growing and shrinking while the search
as a fixed-width now I really don't know
why you would create a layout like this
but this is at least how you would do it
and that is it for this lecture I'll see
you in the next one
hey now that you know quite a bit about
how to control the items along the main
axis using stuff like justify content
margins and flex
oona teach you how to control the
content along the cross axis which in
our case goes from top to bottom and by
default the items stretch themselves
across the cross axis to make this a
little bit more apparent let's set the
height of the container here to 100% now
as you can see they stretch across the
axis going from top to bottom regardless
of how tall it is now a quick note on
this height 100% this only works because
we've set the height of the HTML and the
body to 100% if we hadn't done that then
the height of the HTML and the body
would just be whatever the container
forces it to be meaning whatever height
the container needs in order to display
its content and thereby setting the
height to 100% wouldn't have any effect
at all just remove it doesn't do
anything so this is a nice technique for
having the container responsive in the
height as well
setting the HTML on the body to 100% and
the container as well okay so by default
a line items is set to stretch so
misalign items here is the property that
controls the items in the cross axis if
we change it to for example a flex start
as you can see then they're pushed all
the way to the top the start of the
cross axis and they only take up as much
space in the height as they need in
order to display their content we can
also do flex and I'll push them
downwards to the end of the axis and of
course you can also do center that'll
Center it o as a little side note air on
a point out that flex box is great for
centering an item inside of a container
for example let's say that we only had
one item here it could be the button
with the X inside of it like this for
example
and we could easily Center this inside
of the container using a line items and
combining it with justify content and
doing Center there so now as you can see
the button is centered no matter how you
changed the container so that's nice
little trick which I found often comes
in handy when building various layouts
okay so let's change this back again and
remove this one because finally I'm
going to show you how to align a single
item at a time let's for example target
the logout item we then do a line self
it's at that for example to flex
start right push just that item to the
top of the axis now what I want you to
do is to make this home item appear all
the way at the bottom here so go ahead
and pause the screencast jump into the
code and make it happen
when you've done it come back and I'll
show you how to do it to swallow okay so
hopefully you managed to do that let's
look at how I would going to first
target me oh Michael and we're going to
give it a line self insert that reflects
and that's the end of the cross axis is
all the way here at the bottom and now
we have this really weird layout the
kind of a diagonal navbar which also
works responsibly and a very weird way
so I have no idea how you want layout
like this you've at least learned how to
do it using align self and align items
and that was it I'll see you in the next
screencast
hey in this lecture we're going to talk
about flex direction column because up
until now views the default way of
laying out items which is flex direction
row meaning that the Flex container lays
out items along the row going from left
to right so now let's try flex direction
column as you can see that changes the
container so that it lays out the items
going from top to bottom and this again
means that justify content no longer
controls how the items are stacked
across the horizontal line but rather
how they're stacked across the vertical
line and that's because the main axis
now is vertical going from top to bottom
and not horizontal going from left to
right which it was when we had flex
direction row like that okay
so let's try an ad justify confident and
set it you for example flex and that
doesn't result in any change actually so
why is that well it's because the height
of the container is not set explicitly
it's just as tall as the content inside
of it forces it to be meaning that has
no extra space when it's trying to push
all the content towards the Flex end
which is the bottom of the container
what we have to do is explicitly set the
height of the container to 100% and very
can see now the container takes up the
entire window or almost at least and the
justify content touches all the content
down to the bottom of the main axis now
just as a reminder when using this
height 100% you also have to set the
height of the HTML and the body to 100%
here okay if we change the Flex and the
two flex start all the content would s
be on top here that's also the default
way of doing it as you can see we can
also do Center and that will Center it
okay let's now look at alliant items
which controls the layout in the cross
axis which now is horizontal going from
left to right if we want to shove the
items over to the right hand side for
example we can do
eine items and goo flex and that'll push
the item towards the end of the cross
axis as you might remember by default
it's set to stretch to scripts so they
stretch themselves all the way from the
start of the axis to the end of the axis
let's also try flex start and of course
we can do Center now I want to give you
a little task I want you to make the
content appear in the bottom right
corner here so go ahead and pause the
screencast do that and when you come
back I'll show you the solution as well
so hopefully you pause the screencast
and completed the task let's look at the
solution we want this chunk of items
here to appear down in the bottom right
corner and let's first push it all the
way over to the right then willing to
target the cross axis the aligned items
and change that to flex and as this is
the end of the cross axis the horizontal
one now we also need to place it in the
end of the main axis which now goes from
top to bottom meaning that we'll also
set just by content to flex and and
there you go in the next lecture we're
going to look at wrapping so stay tuned
and I'll see you there
Hey in this lecture you're going to
learn how to wrap items in flexbox so
here we have our standard navbar it
contains three items and each of them
are just as wide as the content inside
of them forced them to be what I want to
do now is target each of the icons give
them width of 300 pixels as you can see
they now fill the entire width of the
container however they're clearly not
300 pixels wide each they're scaled
downwards as the container is less than
900 pixels wide in total however if we
widen it here as you can see they become
300 pixels wide when the container is
wide enough so what happens here is that
flexbox won't allow you to set the width
explicitly if there's not enough within
the container itself to fill that
content it'll automatically scale it
down and by default it won't allow you
to for example push any of the items
down to the next row and that's because
flexbox has a flex rata pre and set to
no rack by default it doesn't allow
wrapping meaning you can only have one
row or one column along your given main
axis but if we change this to happen
instead you can see that it now allows
you to wrap the content because you have
the home here the search here and when
it tries to fit in the log out doesn't
have enough room to add the item so it
wraps and puts it on the next line the
next row and if we shrink the container
even more it'll wrap so that there's
only one item in each row now the total
width of the container is less than 600
pixels meaning it can only fit one 300
pixel item on each row however if it has
enough room it fills up with as many
items it can on each row okay so that
was a quick intro to flexwrap i'll see
you in the next lecture
hey there in this lecture we're going to
take a deep dive into the Flex property
which we talked about in previous lesson
so now I have a very simple version of
our navbar this time it only contains
two items the home item and the logout
item and they both have a flex of one
that means that they'll take up half a
space each and they'll grow and shrink
with the size of the container however
as I mentioned earlier flex is actually
a shorthand property for three other
properties they're called flex bro
thanks shrink flex ASIS and setting flex
equal to rhom and when we set the Flex
value we're actually setting all three
of these and even just writing one is
actually also kind of a short tab
because what we're actually saying here
is one rum zero my first number is the
grow value the second is the shrink
value and the third is the basis value
so this is also the same as setting one
one zero so it's kind of three levels
here you can write it the hard way
doing like this or the slightly easier
way doing it like this or the absolutely
easiest way doing it like this okay this
might seem confusing so let's actually
go through these appellees here one by
one I'll remove this one and also
comment out the Flex grow and flex
string now copy that over here now we're
gonna do is set the Flex basis on both
of the items we'll set it to 200 pixels
and do that on both now we have a
container with two items which each are
set to 200 pixels at least they'll be
200 pixels if the container is more than
400 pixels wide so Flex basis is a way
of setting the base width of the element
so they allows
at 200 pixels regardless of how much
extra space there is in the container if
there's less than 400 pixels they'll
actually start to shrink but that's
something we're gonna look at a little
bit later so let's not get ahead of
ourselves there let's move on to the
Flex grow if we cut this out here and
paste it in there same thing here now
you can see they actually grow with the
width of the container so flex grow
basically decides how much of the extra
space should be distributed to the
various items if we set them to 0 on
both lease this extra space will not be
distributed to either home or log out
since they both have a flex grow of 0
however if for example log out gets a
flex scroll of 1 it'll take up all of
the remaining space and home will get
nothing on the remaining space but as
you saw if the home also has value 1 it
too will grow with the size of the
container and now as these values are
identical both have won the flexbox
layout will distribute the extra space
evenly across the two items so these two
numbers also work in relation to each
other if we set logout to 2 you'll see
that the logout grows twice as quick as
the home this will be a bit more
apparent if we use a larger number for
example 5 now when it grows you can see
that the logout is clearly glowing
faster than the home item and actually
it's growing 5 times faster so just to
reiterate on that if we set the both of
these to 0 then we have the extra space
on the side and the wider we make the
container the more extra space we have
however if we give the log out click
scroll 1 it will take up all of the
available space and grow into it we make
only the home have a flex Grove 1 it
will take up all the available space
grow into it and if both of them are set
to 1 they will distribute the extra
space evenly across each other ok so now
let's move on to
shrink let's set these like scroll
values back to zero
copy the shrink down here and down here
so as you remember even though we've set
the basis here to 200 pixels the Flex
container will force them to be less
than 200 pixels if the container is less
than 400 pixels like now now there may
be other than fiction
150 pixels each or something like that
and that is because Flex shrink is set
to 1 meaning that they will both shrink
at an equal rate and this is actually
the default value for flag' shrink so
while the grow is by default set to 0
the Flex shrink is by default set to 1
meaning they fire remove this one and
this one will still have the same
behavior
they both shrink and an equal rate let's
get them back again
okay now let's change the Flex drink to
zero for the home item what will happen
now is that when we reach the 400 pixel
threshold and the items will have to
start shrinking the log out will do all
the shrinking while the home stays at
200 pixels so the log out is doing all
the shrinking since that as flex shrink
is set to 1 while home thus none of the
shrinking since this flex shrink set to
0 now let's change the Flex drink on
this one to something greater than 1 and
see what happens then let's add 5 for
example rabbits now is that when we
reach the threshold the whole item is
shrinking much quicker than the logout
item it's actually shrinking 5 times
faster than the logout item so these
numbers work in relation to each other
meaning that you have to look at both
the numbers this one and this one to
understand how one of the numbers play
out on the page because now log out has
a flex drink of 1 and as you can see it
shrinks really slowly because one is a
small number in relation to 5 order if
we take this back again and set the Flex
drink of home to zero when suddenly
logout grows all the shrinking because
one
relation to zero is infinitely more okay
so let's rewrite these two here
through the behavior we want we want
conflicts crow actually it could be at
one Romanus like shrink to be at one and
do the same thing here and have reflux
bases stay at 200 so now they grow and
shrink at the same rate and they have
and they are 200 pixels by default so
now we can get back to the shorthand
again we're going to do flex and run run
200 pixels this is the exact same thing
as this meaning we can remove this and
also drop it or we create this logout
like okay so finally I want to give you
the task for this lecture what I want
you to do now yes that once this
container here crosses the threshold of
400 pixels I want you to make the logout
item grow 10 times as fast as the home
item so go ahead and do that and when
you come back to the screencast I'll
show you the solution okay hopefully you
pause the screencast and did the
assignment it's really easy actually if
you want the logout to grow 10 times as
fast as the home item you simply set the
Flex grow which is the first one of the
3 to 10 now as you can see the logout
grows really fast and home grows really
slowly however when they start shrinking
they both shrink at an equal rate
meaning when they're less than 200
pixels they both shrink and grow
actually at the same rate but once they
crept across the 200 pixel threshold
about here the logout takes over ok so
that's it and I'll see you in the next
lecture
be they're really nice thing about
flexbox is that it has so called source
order independence meaning that you can
move around on the items cardless of how
they're laid out in the markup and an
example of this is the order properly so
let's see how it works
we have the three items home search and
logout in the container here and I've
given them number as that simply makes
it easier to follow what's going on here
I've also given them classes of item 1
item 2 item 3 let's head over to the CSS
and give the item to for example order
property 1 and what happened here is
that the search jumped over to the third
spot where the logout used to be and
I've not changed anything in the HTML
the source order is still 1 2 3 but the
order on a page is 1 3 2 and you might
be a little bit confused about why
setting the value to 1 results in it in
placed all the way at the end and that
is because by default the order is set
to 0 so whatever items that have an
order above 0 for example one who
replaced at the end however if we give
it a value below 0 for example minus 1
it'll be placed in the beginning so
let's also add a selector for item 1 and
item 3 default they're all set to 0 so
if we set them to 0 I won't result or
anything if we want the first item to
for example pair at the last spot can
give it a value above 0 for example 5 or
4 or 3 or 2 doesn't matter stay at the
end of the main axis as long as its
order is above the order on the rest of
the items so what I want you to do now
is to make these three items appear in
the opposite direction of how they're
originally laid out meaning it's 3 to 1
instead of 1 to 3 and I want you to do
that using both passive and
negative numbers in the order here so go
ahead and do that now and when you come
back I'll show you how to do this well
okay so hopefully you completed that
task let's now do it ourselves
the second item here say at the same
place that's the first and the third
which will basically be swapped and
we're gonna use positive and negative
numbers so I'll start with targeting the
third item the logout one and set this
to minus one now that's first and then
we have to set the item one the home to
be a positive number one and now that is
laid out towards the end three two one
and that was it I hope you managed to do
this as well and congratulations you've
completed the main section of this
flexbox course so give yourself a pat on
the back and if you have any questions
feel free to ask that in the QA section
and and I'll answer it as soon as
possible thank you
hey in this bonus lecture you're going
to learn how to create a fully
responsive navbar which adapts itself to
various screen sizes using a bunch of
the concepts you've learned so far
including flex Gro flex shrink flex
basis flex wrap and the order property
so here is our navbar it has four items
and it's only the search item which is
flexing as you can see it grows and
shrinks with the size of the container
and that's because we've given the
search item a flex value of one while
the others are only as wide as the
content inside of them force them to be
I've also added a bit different styling
to this example as you can see we're
only using one background color as that
looks a little bit nicer and the reason
we used different background colors in
previous examples was because there was
a bit more pedagogical however by now
you should know the basics of how
flexbox works so we don't need different
colors in the HTML you'll also see a few
changes as the container we're using an
unordered list and list items as the
Flex items as this is a little bit more
semantically correct for creating a
navbar the search item can be found here
and as you can see I've added an input
field so you can actually write inside
this search field nothing happens if you
try searching for anything
now this navbar works well on wide
screens and it works well too right
about here where it starts breaking
because the search suddenly can't fit
anymore so what we want to do here is
actually allow the container to wrap and
to place two items instead of four on
each of the two rows so let's do that
we'll head over to the index dot CSS and
we'll simply create a media query set it
to 600 pixels
and inside of it
forget the container and allowing strap
because right now it won't wrap
regardless of how narrow you make it
simply will not allow you to add items
on multiple rows it will only allow one
row to change that will do flex wrap and
set it to wrap as you can see now it'll
allow wrapping here the logout wrap down
to the second row though this doesn't
look very nice let's go back here and
we'll target the items but it's at their
Flex value to flex grow rum flex shrink
one who ever flex basis 50% because
that'll make each row fit two items like
that and as you can see we have home and
profile in the first row and search and
logout on the second row each taking up
50% of the total with now I actually
want to align the search place holder
text in the center instead of at the
left hand side so I'll go search in
perks and do line so that looks a bit
better this has nothing to do with the
Flex box itself it's just a design
choice okay so now we have two different
states this one and this one and it's
actually pretty nice however if the
screen becomes even narrower look what
will happen it'll actually break at this
point
pushing the search and the log out onto
a row each wherever home and profile can
still fit on one row so flex box will
allow them to stay on the same row when
it reaches this point each item it's a
single each now I don't want this middle
stage here this one the vertical layout
is good for very narrow screens mobile
phones for example and this one is good
for a bit wider screens but this layout
isn't really that useful
so let's rather control this by creating
another media query this time
copied from here and added that 400 for
example and what we need to do now is at
this point
I'll get each of the items like we're
doing here however instead of giving
each item 50% of the row in the width
we'll give them a hundred percent so
I'll just copy this actually and change
this to a hundred percent as you can see
now the breakpoint at 400 pixels to
reach here gives us a clean transition
from this state to this state now
finally what I want to do is move the
search all the way to the bottom because
I think it makes sense to have the
search at the bottom when the layout is
fully vertical to do that well target
the search and simply give it an order
of 1 and it comes down to the bottom and
remember that's because by default order
is set to 0 for all these items and
whatever item which has an order above
the others for example this one has one
which is above 0 will appear after the
others so that was it I hope you learned
something feel free to play around with
this and change it however you want and
if you have any questions just leave
them in the Q&A section thank you
hey and welcome to this bonus lecture
where we are simply going to experiment
a little bit with an image grid in
flexbox
if you've seen my CSS grid course you'll
probably recognize this grid ass I've
simply formed one of the screencasts
there and changed round things a little
bit and I actually do recommend you to
create image grids in CSS grid as that
is made for two-dimensional layouts
while flexbox is mainly one-dimensional
however you can't recreate quite a lot
of cool grids in Flex box as well so
let's just jump into it and play around
a little bit here we have our images
they can also be found in the IMG folder
over here and we have the basic set up
here the container just has a display of
flex and as you can see that just lines
up the images after each other and there
are a bunch of them and they're way out
of the flexbox container because flex
box won't allow you to wrap any of the
items it'll force everything to be on
the same line
so let's first actually scale these
images down a little bit
let's give them a width of 850 pixels
and a height of 100 pixels now that'll
change their aspect ratio a little bit
but let's not care about that because it
looks kind of nice okay and now we want
the images to wrap of course and as you
remember to do that we could do flex
wrap and which by default it's no wrap
and we're just going to remove the no
and boom you can see now wraps a nice
little image grid however as you can see
at this point they're skewed over to the
left-hand side so one thing we can do to
make it a little bit nicer is to do
justify content it's at that center now
center it looks pretty
we can also try these around for example
that'll add some space around the images
though here you can see the problem when
flexbox only can fill three items on the
last row the space around the images
will be different than these of course
resulting in this funny looking grid ish
layout here but with a different type of
grid down here there's not an easy way
to have these three images over at the
left hand side for example so that only
the last spot here will be open when you
do space around it'll do space around on
each of the rows separately if we did X
start wooden Sentret like I did
previously now we have much more space
here and here even though we have this
more grid dish layout okay
so what if we want these images here to
be flexible in their rhythm now we've
just hard-coded their width and height
though what we can do instead is
actually use percentages here let's do a
hundred percent and 100 percent and
we'll also do object fit hover move this
justify content and now it looks really
broken just hang on a minute what we'll
also do is we'll target the items
themselves and I'll give them a flex
value of let's grow one like a shrink
one and base width for example 150
pixels which we've previously had now
you can see they scale up and down and
also shuffle around when needed so here
their base with 150 pixels but they're
allowed to grow and shrink and the
images themselves just take up whatever
space each of the Flex item has got
available and with the object fit cover
they take up all the width and all the
height and cover the entire window and
that will result in you not seeing all
of the images in even time if that's
important this is not a good solution
however you just want most of the images
to appear in the box don't care if it's
cropped a little bit
is actually a pretty nice solution so
ever xbox lays out as many items as it
can on each of the rows as an evenly
distributed throughout gross so when it
gets to this point where we have ten
images here and our eleventh image that
which is the last one down here it'll be
placed on a single row meaning it'll be
five times as wide as the others just an
optimal however these widths looks
pretty nice now we also have some big
images here given them class names of
biggie here I want to try out is
actually do container and then target
those big ones and here I'll actually
target normal ones specifically as I've
given random classes of more and more as
you can see here and now they're the
same however if we give the big ones 250
pixels in base width you can see that
that works as well it scales up and down
however now we've said that we want the
big images to start at 250 pixels width
and the normal image is to start at 150
pixels width and they are both to grow
the container has room for it meaning
you have this pretty cool looking grid
okay feel free to play around with this
perhaps with just the values here you
can drag and drop some more images in
here maybe some vertical and horizontal
images and try to adjust their flick
spaces basically do whatever you want so
how's it I hope you learn something
thank you